hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play outlast
okay no time to wait we got to get right
back into the fray there's a mystery to
solve and there is a giant asylum to
escape and there's also a giant monster
who wants to stab me in the butt
apparently so I have to get out of here
to peak hold Curie's there some reason I
need to peek around this corner there's
some reason that would be the reason
okay so we got something over here
oh are you actually alive are you one of
those moms are you one of those mom are
you one of the if will you let me finish
it sentence you one of those monsters or
what okay I think I'm supposed to go
this way don't mind me
keep on sleeping just sleep away all
your troubles nothing to worry about
here yep yeah just fine soft kitty warm
kitty
was this gonna be a problem
a crowd of broken men watch a dead
Channel they look like patients they
survived what happened here but nobody's
home what does that even mean what does
it mean
pin Liga I already saw that okay what am
I supposed to do
can I just go bathroom
don't mind me
don't mind me just you are weird okay
come on what the hell okay I guess I
don't need to sneak up they're not gonna
do anything to me what's with that music
I mean it's awfully nice with the whole
choir going on there but okay okay what
was that that is that dead guy good good
was wondering while I was gonna find
another one of those let's find what the
dead guy wants to tell me excuse me sir
oh you have us some sort of badge okay I
got a security card what that means I do
not know collect it up dig through my
reporters notebook I have a key card for
security control hopefully that means
that I can get a gun probably not I
don't think I get guns in here okay my
car doesn't go there okay so obviously I
think I got to go back these guys are
just chill accident hey what's up bro
what's up man what are you doing how's
it hanging you don't look so good may
want to get your uh
everything checked out okay how's it
going man what you watching oh I'm sorry
mine your way to scratch your face if
I'm annoying you
oh no okay so what okay I'm assuming
that I still probably need to sneak
around this guy because once I don't I
really have no idea
buddy yeah just sit back down there I'm
gonna go this way
I knew you were gonna do something you
son of a [ __ ] what the hell man
freak I'm sorry I shouldn't have called
you a freak you probably just very
sensitive about that oh you're
freakiness going on okay is there like a
security thing in the middle of here
maybe see ah what's this
what did I get no it was a journal
thingy
wait no warrant for seizure um let's see
it's a warrant for catastrophic security
failure of psychiatric center with a man
in danger of environment contamination
contamination with what the shadows okay
looks like surrender complete authority
to its agents okay all right gotcha
gotcha gotcha so something went wrong in
this place
what well you can't just do that and not
have something to show for it
hello okay it's just gonna go this way
don't mind me anyway so why would I want
to look why would I need to do that same
thing you just told me to do if you
didn't catch that it told me that I can
look behind me while running the press
and Kure why would I ever want to do
that that's really cool and all great
trick ill ah someone left their severed
head here and right in mind
you got your intestines in my severed
head you've got your severed head in my
intestines there's a lot of dead stuff
okay okay another thing another thing
okay that's I think okay I was wrong
wasn't the thing there's nothing oh it
was a thing the door closed
okay there seems to be a blood-stained
bathroom here
well it's barge right in why don't we
knock knock somebody using this you're
not dead are you witness witness to what
the apocalypse uh-huh Oh someone didn't
flush
now what bad manners you actually you're
gonna do something okay you're dead
you're very very very dead you better
stay that way I don't think there are
actually zombies here so I don't think I
have to worry about that okay I got that
security good thing I went here to get
that thing it's like I know what I'm
doing okay
hello lots of technology happening Oh No
why would I need to hide Oh No
they lie they lie about what we got here
to consider God technology hacking this
accessing security system well that's
gonna take a while
I'm guessing I don't wanna be oh hi yeah
how's it going don't do that
hey how's it going buddy and you do oh
you're a big fella
ancient don't find me yeah what did you
call me oh that's right walk away after
calling me names get out of here if you
really wanted to kill me you may not
have wanted to throw me off that ledge
did he say enhanced interrogation there
weren't any uh there weren't any
subtitles for that guy at the end there
something about enhancing that Saku lime
actually crawling on the ground that's
weird
it's weird because I actually have a
body and I'm oh that's what I'm doing
Wow that's counterintuitive okay so
anyway carry on okay so I saw a guy run
into that room I think I'm pretty sure I
don't want to go in there it's dark in
here
any other dead bodies yep whoa okay I am
standing in his goop why am i standing
in his goop dear Sirs the full report
pending no immediate action is required
on the part of the Murkoff Corp the
profit potential project walrider
remains staggeringly high four
fatalities litigation evidences managed
correctly managed impossible okay so
they're worried about covering their ass
so I'm doing that weird sound whenever I
take off a note that's strange
okay so they're worried about covering
their ass for some sort of lawsuit which
I'm assuming that they're doing
extremely illegal activities while
they're here okay let's check in here
oh you locked yourself in there eh want
some privacy I understand okay can I get
through here oh I need to go back and
access the security console that's right
baby
better look with my camera okay thanks
it kind of disturbing all right
oh wait no the powers off hey mr. priest
'hey man if you really wanted me to help
me you might not want him to do that
okay where did that big guy go what did
the big guy go hello okay that's the
meat locker over there and things seem
to have gotten much worse over here okay
let's go downstairs because it's the
only way I haven't gone yet
oh look water great how about that slip
through the gap bad stuff happened last
time I tried it
who's that all is that hey don't be
doing that
don't be doing random noises this game
likes to do lots of random ass noises
okay
Wednesday 10th of February 1954 hypnotic
experiment research which was continued
in building 13 Colorado using the
following subjects a bridge material
posthypnotic tonight before enacted mrs.
Jackson Pierce immediate press to a deep
hypnotic state with no further
suggestion blah blah blah
fear of firearms awakened miss Jackson
failing this she picked up a nearby
pistol and fired in that miss Jackson
what instructed that a raid would be so
great that she would not hesitate to
kill Jackson for failure failing to
awaken what she carried out the
suggestions to a letter firing the gun
at Jackson unloaded pneumatic and then
proceeding to fall into a deep sleep
after process proper suggestions were
made what is going on here this is so
weird expressed absolute denial about
that the foregoing sequence had happened
this is so strange so it's just like
they're doing random experiments to do
with psychiatric miss in them mental
stuff all sorts of stuff that I don't
know anything about so I seem to have
reached a dead end is there something in
here that I need I picked up the only
note here there's got to be something oh
maybe there's a power switch that's what
happened because maybe that priest guy
flipped the switch down here what oh
okay oh this is a different area I
thought I was looping back okay nobody
Oh almost out of battery well I got more
I think I switch them out and when
needed
it is dark down here but I think that's
the panel than I need let's go to it
turn on the two gas pumps in the main
breaker what the hell it was really that
easy to show dead body okay
you know I know that a lot of people are
gonna draw some comparisons to amnesia
when they play this game but uh don't
start doing that it's actually quite a
different experience I have to admit
very different hello is anybody in there
is anybody here
battery okay just about out of battery
hopefully that'll shot I hit reload that
did it okay got it
all right one pump ready to go just need
the other one and I'm sure nothing bad
is gonna pop out of me
I'm sure I'm so certain what's that
close it after we close the damn door
I'm pressing the damn button okay that
was a thumpy guy big big a whole bashing
his way into here Oh
oh oh oh no no you're strong ain't you
you can bash down doors just another
ghost yeah alright okay that's my first
encounter with an actual patrolling guy
hello where are you going
how are you even able to see down here
what are you doing are you doing you're
so ugly
oh you're ugly good stop mumbling to
yourself what is that guy doing is he's
just gonna stand there
good yeah move on I was about to say he
was gonna hear me if I started going
down into the water cuz that's all there
is around here water in the ground I
must be behind you behind you
I'm going for it going for it I'm going
so slow why am I going so slow now all
the sudden I'm going way too slow I went
a lot faster before now you definitely
heard that okay you're at them push it
push it push it push it push it
okay hide in the corner until he breaks
the door down and then we'll go away
and then we'll have a fun ol time yeah
I'm gonna win did you hear that
okay hear that no need to waste battery
life
I'm gonna do the same thing I'm gonna
sneak out when he gets halfway okay hi
buddy hey buddy okay here we go
what what okay that was weird
I'm gonna assume that what you're gonna
do is you're gonna patrol back and forth
oh are you leaving please leave please
be leaving I think he's gone but just in
case I'm gonna go the long way around to
the generator okay don't know how he's
out hearing this but I think he is gone
okay yeah he's gone okay hi dad
ahh what main breaker Oh main breaker
something else it must be over here
are you over here oh it was way too
close
ah dead body I'm trying to get this
you're stopping me from hiding dead body
you're really not helping me at all here
there we go I will get past him how do
we get past him I gotta stop wasting
batteries it's like you know in lamb
neva I wish indeed Lantern the oil was
he doing what is he doing over there
what in the world are you doing tell me
your secrets there's got to be something
over here right
this was a dumb idea there's gotta be a
breaker in there
hi hey hey you give up and give up man
you give up good get here get here get
here are you doing
what are you doing house quick okay yeah
looks like he doesn't want to follow me
this way but he's still hanging around
this guy's hard to get away from what I
know where that breaker is there's a
ding dong dam breaker I don't know where
the breaker is we're just gonna do this
dance over and over again
okay what are you doing
you're such an a-hole it's going one of
the side no okay it's going one of the
side rooms where you're not gonna be a
total jerk where do you go okay he's
going in a side room so this gives me an
opportunity to actually check this room
over here don't hear me you don't hear
anything you don't hear anything okay
does that say electric room got it
all right over here vault this and then
we get to the main breaker and then we
do great stuff for all the world to see
that the main breaker no where's the
main breaker oh I get it I was probably
supposed to lead him this way but
whatever whatever who needs to do that
when you can run like a scared little
girl in that you totally fine I know why
didn't I just leave the window I came in
why didn't they do that okay so I can
hit the main generator now I think okay
let's go let's go let's go where are you
wait where am I which way did they go
was that of something is that oh nothing
the eternal question was that if
something or was out of nothing okay I
gotta go back but he wasn't coming
closed or hide and then wait till he
goes away you didn't hear anything
nothing nothing happened what about this
door nothing happened I know it's dark
but it's supposed to be done he's not
supposed to see me
yeah that's right that's right okay so I
just gotta get back
he's being a son of a [ __ ] I can't get
back oh this is much harder than dealing
with amnesia monsters cuz he doesn't go
away he does not go away he does not
give a flying poop what I do okay okay
don't pop out anywhere right I'm in the
clear okay I'm good all right
oh that was an ordeal oh it's a bit of
an ordeal I hope it's over all right oh
that sounds like chase music it's a
chase music please tell me that's not
chase me oh it is chase music oh boy we
could get out of here where do I go what
do we do okay open the door
all right so that will do it for this
part we're a little longer than I
planned but that's okay I may go longer
don't matter so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos it I've done and as always I
will see
sound I want to know